c'est une première journée de régate au
contact qu'offrent les manches de ce
vendredi
un parcours dans la baie de
fort-de-france par vent modéré et mer
calme
l'idéal pour enflammer trois journées de
compétition sur le plan d'eau des
équipages au profit les supports
différents
un équipage 100% féminin habitué des
régates martiniquaise et qui veut faire
parler de lui
une synthoise traditionnel de la
guadeloupe
mais barré par les yoleurs de christophe
d'aidé ou encore les racines de nicolas
gillet et jean-michel figuères deux
anciens vainqueurs qui ont bien
l'intention d'en découdre
objectif du désormais directeur de
course attirer de plus en plus de monde
on est dans les plus belles baies du
monde c'est vrai on a un stade nautique
qui est magnifique pour arriver à
travailler là on a changé de forme à
cette année puisqu'on fait une journée
dans la baie de fort-de-france et puis
ensuite on fait le tour de la martinique
donc on cherche vraiment là aussi
l'événement sportif puisque pour aller
ceux qui vont passer une catégorie de
bateaux va passer par le nord et fera
75000 dans la journée donc c'est
vraiment sportif et une catégorie va
passer par le sud par le rocher du
diamant
on peut pas considérer ça comme une
promenade de santé parce que c'est quand
même une régate mais c'est plus
confortable
donc effectivement on essaye de l'ouvrir
à l'ensemble des concurrents possibles
petite déception avec des défections de
dernière minute de bateaux attendus
d'antigua-et-barbuda et un retard de
l'équipage guadeloupéen de rodolphe
c'est faux le skipper de la dernière
route du rhum ne s'est pas présenté à
temps pour la première manche mais il
devrait rejoindre la flotte courant de
la journée